for many students figuring out financial
aid is a key part of the college
application process the deadline to
commit to a college is next Wednesday
student loan debt soared to 1.5 seven
trillion dollars last year Democratic
presidential hopeful senator Elizabeth
Warren unveiled a plan this week to
eliminate tuition at public colleges it
also erases up to fifty thousand dollars
in student loan debt for every person
with a household income under a hundred
thousand dollars CBS News business
analyst Jill Schlesinger is here with
how your family can get the best
financial aid plan Jill good morning
good morning so let's start first about
Senator Warren how would her plan work
so essentially it is advertised as a way
to level the playing field and this is a
great probably aspiration I don't think
this is actually going to happen but
again free tuition at public two and
four-year institutions with a little
help from the states but also this idea
of debt forgiveness and I think this is
a tough one because I think a lot of
people are going to have a hard time
saying hey I paid off my student loans
how come other people are getting their
student loans wiped away so and a
whopper of a price tag 640 billion
dollars and funded with a millionaire
and billionaires tax so a 2% wealth tax
on families who have assets over fifty
million dollars and then a three percent
if you've got more than a billion all
right I'll pay the three percent of a
billion dollar so that's what might
happen what about now in the student aid
process what are some things people need
to keep in mind
first of all these letters are really
confusing because there is no uniform
way that colleges and universities have
to report to families about what is loan
what is grant what is scholarship so
when you get that letter
be very careful families are often
confusing loans and grants that's number
one number two when you look at that
letter no it's for one year only so that
first year a lot of families presume
this will be the next two years three
years and you know what it doesn't
necessarily mean that's the case and
also understand there's a difference
between a federal direct subsidized and
unsubsidized loan subsidized loan means
that when the money is dispersed they
wait to start the in
his calculation until you graduate an
unsubsidized loan that clock starts
ticking as soon as the money is
dispersed hey parents those PLUS loans
those are tickin away too whether your
kid graduates or not how do you find out
what the interest rates are on the
student loans very difficult not in the
letters there's no information about the
letters we just sign up for a loan if
you don't know the interest as well and
and that's the problem and so again it's
an extra step families have to do their
home or a couple places to look
consumerfinance.gov the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau has a way to
compare different offers there's also a
really cool service called men money -
mentor.com it helps students a free
service to help navigate this process
this is tens of thousands of dollars
please just don't sign on the dotted
line without doing homework all right
Jill you need to go to school to learn
how to read the letters you go to school
thanks a lot you know